we're told a certain pet store chain has
three types of dog food and each comes
in bags of two different sizes
matrix a represents the store's
inventory at location a
where rows are food types and columns
are bag sizes so see it's store a that's
what matrix a is telling us they're
telling us we have three different types
of food
three different types of dog food and
then they each come in two different
sizes so for example
type one dog food in size one they have
five bags of that while type two dog
food in size two they have nine bags of
that all right that's fair enough
matrix b represents the store's
inventory at location b all right same
thing for store b
matrix c
represents how many more or less bags of
each type and size there are in location
a
relative to location b
complete matrix c
so pause this video and see if you can
have a go at that so we need to fill in
the entries here of
matrix c
all right now let's do this together so
let me just review what it just told us
matrix c represents
how many more bags of each type and size
there are in location a
relative to location b
so for example this first entry right
over here we want to know how many more
bags of type 1 size 1 there are in
location a than there are in location b
well i would take the number that there
are in location a and then from that
subtract how many there are in location
b that would tell me how many more i
have in location a
so if i take 5
minus
8
what am i going to get
well i'm going to get
negative 3 right over here and you might
already be recognizing what's happening
for every corresponding entry i'm going
to subtract the entry from matrix b from
the mate entry in matrix a or another
way to think about it is if i take
matrix a
and i subtract
matrix b i'm going to get matrix c i'm
just going to subtract all of the
corresponding entries so if i do 7
minus 6 and that is going to be 1. i'm
just going to color code this if i do 3
minus 10 that's going to be negative 7
if i do
i'm running out of colors if i do 9
minus 12
that is also going to be
negative
3
and then
if i do
this brown color 10
minus 5 that is going to be positive 5
and then if i do 15
minus 9 that is positive 6.
so we can see that for example type 1
size 2
we have one more in store a than we have
in store b but if we think about type
two
size one
it shows us that that store a has
actually seven fewer of that than store
b does
now we have one last question here that
is below the screen but let me scroll
down here
so they tell us that matrix d is defined
as follows or defines as follows make a
little grammatical is defined
as follows d is equal to a plus b
what does matrix d represent so they're
not asking us to calculate a plus b not
asking us to add the matrices but you
know how to do it you would add the
corresponding entries but what does d
represent
well if you add the corresponding
entries remember this is the inventory
of store a this is the inventory of
store b
so if you were to add them the matrix d
would tell you the combined inventories
of a and b for each of the types and
sizes